>> Sean: AND TONIGHT WE HAVE
EVEN MORE BIG BREAKING
DEVELOPMENTS IN OUR QUEST TO
HOLD THOSE WHO ABUSED POWER AND
THOSE WHO ARE CORRUPT
ACCOUNTABLE.
AS THE DNI CHIEF JOHN RATCLIFFE
DECLASSIFIED INFAMOUS
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
ASSESSMENT ANNEXED ON RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE, AND WE NOW KNOW
THAT IT LEFT OUT KEY DETAILS AND
RED FLAGS ABOUT WHAT THEY KNEW
ABOUT CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
IT ALSO PROVES HOW MR. SUPER
PATRIOT JAMES COMEY MISLED
PRESIDENT TRUMP ABOUT THE DIRTY
DOSSIER.
IT’S SALACIOUS AND UNVERIFIED.
THE WARRANT WAS USING THE
DOSSIER AS THE BASIS OF THE PHIS
APPLICATION AND HE SIGNED THREE
OF THEM.
THIS ALL COMES AS THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HAS NO
AUTHORIZED SUBPOENAS FOR OVER 50
OFFICIALS IN THE CROSSFIRE
HURRICANE INVESTIGATION.
NOW JOINING A SENATE JUDICIARY
CHAIRMAN LINDSEY GRAHAM.
SENATOR, YOU HAVE BLOCKBUSTER
TESTIMONY FROM ROD ROSENSTEIN.
KNOWING WHAT WE KNOW NOW, WE
WOULDN’T HAVE SIGNED THAT FISA
APPLICATION, WE NOW KNOW THAT
THE FBI KNEW FROM HIS EARLIEST
DEALINGS, THIS WAS A BRUSH
RESEARCH PROJECT, AND
DIRECTOR WRAY, WHERE ARE YOU?
HE HAS YET TO TURN OVER THOSE TO
THE SENATE AND SLOW WALKING
THAT.
THE HOUSE G.O.P., WE WILL GET
110 REFERRALS IN THE NEXT FEW
DAYS ABOUT LIKING AND MISCONDUCT
MISCONDUCT, AND THE DNI
DECLASSIFICATION.
I WOULD SAY SENATOR, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WERE NOT ONLY
LIED TO, THEY WERE LIED TO
REPEATEDLY AND THESE PEOPLE
WE’VE IDENTIFIED DID EVERYTHING
WE REPORTED AND MORE.
>> NOBODY SEEMS TO GIVE A DAMN
IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
SO JUST THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH
COVERAGE WAS GIVEN TO THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
TWO AND HALF YEARS AND
$25 MILLION.
IN JANUARY 17, COMEY PROVIDES
PRESIDENT TRUMP A COPY OF THE
STEELE DOSSIER ANCESTOR THE
PRESIDENT, I DON’T KNOW IF THIS
IS TRUE.
WE CAN’T VERIFY IT, BUT THAT’S
THE SAME DOCUMENT THAT WAS USED
MULTIPLE TIMES TO GET A WARRANT
AGAINST CARTER PAGE FOR COMEY,
McCABE AND OTHERS.
HE FOR SURE SIGNED AN AFFIDAVIT
THING IT WAS RELIABLE.
AND THEY SET THE DOSSIER WAS A
BUNCH OF BARTOK AND UNRELIABLE
HEARSAY.
I HAVE THE TOOLS AS CHAIRMAN TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS AND I
WILL.
I BELIEVE THEY STILL HAVE THEIR
PIN ON AND THAT 99% OF THEM ARE
GOOD AND DECENT PEOPLE.
KNOWING WHAT YOU NOW KNOW AND WE
ALL KNOW, ARE YOU CONFIDENT THAT
THE PEOPLE THAT ABUSE THAT
POWER, THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
CORRUPT, THAT KNEW AND HAD
PREMEDITATED FRAUD IN THE FISA
COURT, PEOPLE INVOLVED HELPING
DONALD TRUMP NOT WIN IT, ARE
THEY GOING TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, LINDSAY?
BECAUSE I THINK I WOULD GO TO
JAIL.
>> LET ME ASK FOR THE QUESTION.
THERE’S AN FBI AGENT WHO THOUGHT
THAT STEEL WASN’T VERY RELIABLE,
AND LO AND BEHOLD THEY WERE ABLE
TO FIND THE RUSSIAN IN THE
PROFESSIONAL THAT IT SOUNDS LIKE
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
THERE’S A MULTIPLE PAGE MEMO
FROM THE INTERVIEW OF THE
RUSSIAN SUB SOURCE IN JANUARY
WHICH BASICALLY IS SHREDDING THE
RELIABILITY OF THE DOSSIER.
THE QUESTION IS, CAN ANYBODY IN
THE FBI GO TO McCABE AND COMEY
AND SAY, BY THE WAY, THE WARRANT
WE’VE BEEN USING IS NO LONGER
RELIABLE.
I FIND IT HARD TO BELIEVE THAT
NOBODY AT THE TOP WAS TOLD BY
THE PROFESSIONALS IN THE
ORGANIZATION THAT OUR CASE FELL
APART.
>> Sean: YOU HAD THE I THOUGHT
THE BIGGEST BLOCKBUSTER TEST
TESTIMONY.
BY THE WAY, YOU WERE CRITICIZED
BECAUSE PEOPLE SAID IT, NOT
MOVING FAST ENOUGH, THERE’S A
TIME INTO PLACE.
WHAT DID IT TELL YOU AND WHAT
ARE THE NEXT STEPS?
>> IT TELLS ME THAT ROSENSTEIN
SIGNED THE WARRANT APPLICATION,
AND IT TELLS ME THAT THE SCOPE
MEMO, AND THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WAS
WRITTEN.
AND DID YOU KNOW THE FBI HAD
LEARNED THAT THE DOSSIER WAS NO
LONGER KNOWS WHAT WAS RELIABLE?
MOST OF THEM ARE GOING TO SAY,
NO.
I DON’T BELIEVE McCABE AND
COMEY COULD POSSIBLY HAVE NOT
KNOWN THAT THE DOSSIER COULD
HAVE BEEN REJECTED BY THE SUB
SOURCE.
I CAN’T BELIEVE THE FBI’S THAT
POORLY RUN.
THE MOST IMPORTANT INVESTIGATION
AND NOBODY TOLD THE TOP OF THE
FBI, BY THE WAY OUR CASE FELL
APART.
I’M NOT GOING TO LOOK FOR PEOPLE
WHO INTERVIEW THE SUB SOURCE GET
BLAMED FOR THIS.
>> Sean: AND SO AT THE END OF
THE DAY, YOU WATCH THE COVERAGE
OF THIS PROGRAM AND OUR ENSEMBLE
CAST, WAS THERE ANYTHING THAT
WAS WRONG THAT YOU SEE AND THERE
WAS THE REST OF THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA THAT WAS TALKING ABOUT
TRUMP AND RUSSIA, TRUMP AND
RUSSIA.
>> I WILL TELL YOU, AND
AUGUST 2017 I FOUND NO EVIDENCE
THAT THERE WAS ANYONE NAMED IN
THE SCOPE MEMO, AND BY AUGUST OF
2017, THE CARTER PAGE WARRANT
APPLICATION WAS COMPLETE.
JANUARY THE FOURTH OF 2017 THE
FBI WITH INSISTED THAT HE
CONTINUE TO BE INVESTIGATED.
EVERY TIME THERE WAS A
STOP SIGN, THEY RAN IT.
EVERY TIME THERE WAS EXCULPATORY
INFORMATION, THEY IGNORED IT.
AS CHAIRMAN, I HAD TOOLS FOR A
SUBPOENA THAT I DIDN’T HAVE
BEFORE.
>> Sean: ALL WE KNOW NOW, AND
YOU WILL GET A LOT MORE
INFORMATION.
IS IT WRONG FOR ME TO
MISCHARACTERIZE THIS AS AN
ATTEMPTED COUP?
WITHIN THE FBI AND INTEL
COMMITTEE, IS THAT A FAIR
STATEMENT?
THAT’S WHAT I SEE.
>> AND IF YOU CARE ABOUT THE
WILL OF LAW YOU SHOULD WANT ME
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS.
DOESN’T MATTER HOW YOU GET HIM
AS LONG AS YOU GET HIM.